[Music]
[Zoom in on sigh reading The Fourth Commandment: Native Food]
[Narrator:] Thou shalt eat only the rations inspected, found fit and provided for thy use.
For verily many native foods  contain poisons more treacherous than a Jap warlord.
Somebody once said: the way to a man's heart is through his stomach.
That is, everybody's but McGillicuddy's.
He's particular! He doesn't like vienna sausage.
He doesn't realize he's in the South Pacific.
He thinks he's in the Brown Derby!
[Daydreaming about turkey and steak]
[Looks like he's about to throw up and pushes
food away]
[Narrator:] Yeah, yeah, I know, Mac. It's monotonous. The same thing day-after-day.
But it's good food and it's good for ya!
[McGillicuddy walks along the road, pausing to pull his belt tighter to a belthole that's labeled Damn Hungry]
[Narrator:] But Mac'll show 'em how to get along on a South Pacific island.
He's a gourmet. A gastronomical Robinson Crusoe.
[Looks up to see bananas]
[Narrator:] Yeah, they look like bananas, they peel like bananas,
but they don't taste like bananas, do they?
You know why?  Because they're not bananas!
They're plantains and you can't eat 'em raw!
[Looks around and sees carrot-like plants]
[Narrator:] Well, what's this? A native victory garden no doubt.
Carrots? Rutabagas? Turnips?
Well, whatever they are, they're sure beauties.
[Sees natives taking care of garden]
[Narrator:] Well kept, well cultivated, but these boys are not just passing the time.
They're passing the fertilizer, and from you-know-where.
[Natives passing pots from head]
While this sort of fertilizer is very effective,
it produces a lot more than just vegetables.
Take a look and you'll see what I mean.
[Magnified view of carrot shows various germs wiggling and barking]
[Mac drops carrots and wipes hands on clothes]
[Narrator:] Nauseating, ain't it?
[McGillicuddy starts walking again, along the way adjusting his belt to a hole that's labeled Starving!!]
[Narrator:] Oh boy, apples!
[Mac gobbles the apples right from the tree, but spits them out after seeing the sign 'Poison fruit']
[Narrator:] Yeah, Mac. Beach apples, good huh?
But you know what they do to ya? Well, the
juice contains an acid, which, uh, uh
attacks the tissue, and you have a chemical reaction,
which results in a sort of a hot foot, uh, or rather a severe
inflammation of the, uh...
Well anyway, it burns the hell out of your
tongue!
[Mac's tongue is on fire and he jumps into nearby water.]
[McGillicuddy sits at the base of a tree, Is reluctantly eating K Rations.]
That's the spririt, Mac! Eat your K Rations
and like it.
[McGillicuddy, sneering:] Nyeeh!
[Smoke wafts over and Mac raises his head to sniff it.]
[Smoke spells out Eat at Dirty Joe's]
[Natives are sitting in a circle around a cooking fire.]
[Narrator:] Mac's brains are still in his stomach.
[He follows the smoke and eats with the natives.]
[Narrator:] Well, the man who came to dinner.
Look, Mac. We're not complaining about your manners,
and it's all right to be friendly with the natives,
but their food is not prepared in the most
sanitary fashion.
Very often, the food which they handle...what you're now packing away, is infested with
germs which are extremely difficult to digest.
[Mac pats his bloated stomach in satisfaction, and hiccups.]
[Narrator:] Oh, pardon me!
[Sign reads: Mess Special Today, Turkey]
[Mac waits in line outside the mess tent, smiling and waving.]
[Narrator:] Yeah, we see you, Mac! This is what you've been waiting for.
Hey, Mac! In a couple of seconds, you'll have that big turkey dinner!
[Mac is seated in front of a large, steaming turkey on a plate.]
[Narrator:] Yum, yum! Roast turkey and cranberries! And...oh, here we go again.
[Mac releases gas and runs to the head.]
[McGillicuddy:] CHARGE!
[Mac returns to find only turkey bones.]
[Narrator:] Too bad, Mac. Ya missed the boat, but they will have turkey again, sometime.
But in the meantime ...
[A plate with sausage is placed in front of Mac, and the end of the sausage flaps open and neighs.]
[Music]